hey reject nation Greg Alba here John we
are going to watch two videos recently
released by Marvel for ant-man and the
wasp first video we got here is the
Marvel featurette it takes two and then
we also have the scenic tour film clip
we're gonna watch them back-to-back and
talked about it before we do that a
couple of things one I don't know if
you've heard us talk about it yet if
you're a regular follower channel but in
case you haven't Saturday July 7 6:00
p.m.
arena Cinna lounge Sunset Boulevard film
therapy with Brianne Chandler in front
of an audience
limited seating Stacy Howie will be
there as well some other guest
appearances might just actually be there
Q&A screening some of our favorite clips
on the big screen over there and maybe a
couple of other surprises as well
Saturday July sounds get your tickets
now in the description box secondly page
from the day shout out for totally
jumbled totally jumbled I think is the
perfect man to shout out for em and and
the wasp reason why he is kind of just a
little human being in real life he is
someone who should be more powerful yet
is kind of weak and he also has a wife
who was like the wasp incredibly
superior much better looking than he'll
ever be doesn't deserve her yet she's
his number two why when she should be
number one and pretty soon your
daughter's gonna have powers too so you
better get ready for that a little
laying that you got over there man
little Cassie Lange anyway TJ insulted
you but complimented your wife
simultaneously take it with a grain of
salt just kidding buddy love you hope we
could talk to you in soon it takes two
is the first one we're watching
[Music]
there's no hope possesses some very
impressive skill she seems more intense
the chance to go back to this character
[Music]
this is I dare you to play
seriously whoa all right let's just hop
on immediately to the actual scene but
apparently we can't blink through when
we're watching it
[Music]
[Music]
I want that lab boys whatever it takes
[Music]
yeah I got a lab on it
[Music]
a lot more of a confident direction here
[Music]
don't blink whatever cars were on coming
up that hill yeah glad that we watched
those back-to-back and in that order
specifically I thought it was a good
setup for what's really to come I find
it fascinating that Evangeline Lilly is
talking about it's so kinetic it's so
hyper don't blink you miss something
what is she talking about watching this
little 50 second clip right here huh
little it was cool that seems like a
unique type of action scene we've all
seen car chases before and they tease
some of that in the trailer with a her
being under the car then blows up at him
the car flips over I'm excited to see
the entire action scene take place
because that seems like a really cool
sequence to be going in and out of
shrinky and going big as we see them did
it when they're in human form in their
costumes but with a car chase that's
unique right there it's got a few cool
car chases in the MCU the spark the on
foot chase that takes place in the
tunnel and Civil War the Black Panther
chase sequence in the movie black
panther this one could top that I think
this movie looks like they're really
stepping up their action I mean the
first one had cool action but that
wasn't the biggest impression I left
with and for this one like so much of
the action scenes that we've seen clip
it's up in the trailers and even this
scene right here it just looks like
they're really confident with what makes
their action special and specific and
that's what's getting me the most kind
of excited for this movie I'm actually
excited that Evangeline Lilly has such a
big role cuz I really liked her in the
first one and I thought she's one of the
best female Marvel protagonists they've
had thus far I think it's an interesting
statement because I don't really know
anyone who walks away from ant-man
talking about her I feel like she's good
and she's serviceable in the film and
she's arguably one of the better female
protagonists absolutely but she's not
someone who I really felt shined in the
movie and then looking at this
featurette and then seeing them one clip
that Marvel has released of the film
it's very Evangeline Lilly centric
it's kind of clever wouldn't they're
doing ant-man and the wasp they're
really promoting their female superhero
front and center for the film even
though it's and the wasp but they're
like she's the big thing we're all
tuning in for and they're putting that
front and center and then the next one
we're getting is Captain Marvel so
you're kind of getting the supporting
player who will be the standout in
ant-man and the wasp with a female
villain and then you're gonna get the
female led superhero film with Captain
Marvel women are winning we have to stop
yet to stop them I hate when I hate them
all of them except for the ones who want
to do stuff with me I like you girls
that's the way to be a real man that's
how men should always be I don't know I
feel Yoshi isn't the biggest character
the flashiest character in the first one
they did leave me wanting more from her
so I'm psyched to see that we will be
getting that it seems like they're gonna
be zipping in and out of miniature mode
like so much more in this movie within
the same sequence like I think back to
em and I'm like oh yeah he either
shrinks down or blows back up and this
is like we're gonna be shrinking and
blowing it and it gives it a certain
zany of a specific aesthetic element
that I think this franchise needs coming
out of the first film with what we
beginning from the marketing and what
we're hearing in the future read the
zaniness the energetic element the
kinetic element is something that's
super essential for them to amp up in
this one and just looking at the t's of
this action sequence we've been saying
forever that looks like they've amped up
the action but you could feel a much
more confident direction with the way
the camera work is being done in the
editing it doesn't feel that Edgar
Wright switcheroo situation this feels
like a dude who really knows what he
wants to do this time around he's gonna
be able to do it so I'm very excited
we're watching this next week at an
early screening they're probably gonna
only be releasing clips after we've
already seen it so this will be like one
of the last reactions we do yeah yeah I
feel like this has the chance to reach
the full potential of the ant-man the
series whatever that is gonna be yeah
the first one I thought was pretty good
and I think this one could be awesome I
just find it funny how we're excited for
wasp ghost elements but no one's really
talking about ant-man yeah I like Paul
Rudd already we already like him he's
the one no one's really talking about
like me fine alright guys well I have
man in the wasp is the first time we've
done a video where we haven't talked
about how let's connect to infinity
Wharf but I don't really care I don't
really care I know I'm actually over
that I thought I thought I'd be in that
mindset still but wow it's amazing how
just give it a couple months and you're
just like I don't care anymore
yeah well guys where do you think the
wasp will actually rank once this movie
is out do you think she will be on the
top of people's lists do you think
she'll be the best female superhero thus
far what is your opinion primary male
demographic at the real rejects you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification BALCO subscribe
buttons are broken you can check us out
on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is music video coverage and hey arena
cinta lounge live events Saturday July 7
6 p.m.
cannot wait for it although we have some
prep to do